as a child growing up in singapore lunar
new year consisted of many traditions
exchanging oranges for red packets full
of money having old people pinch my
cheeks to wish me a prosperous new year
and bake family dinners at my
grandmother's house with more food than
i could ever dream of
since my family moved to the states our
new year's celebrations changed as we
did but the thing i find myself craving
is a pineapple tart these soft buttery
cookies filled with stringy pineapple
goo or a lunar new year staple and my
absolute favorite
the best were always homemade and the
taste
is something i'll never forget the
cookie itself is delicate and pillowy
like something angels float on in heaven
the pineapple filling is sweet yet tart
and just before i'd finish one i'd have
another ready to go in my hand
but here's my problem i don't know how
to make them
and they don't sell them anywhere here
that i have found the only time i get to
eat them is when someone visits me from
singapore and brings me a box but that
does not happen very often
so i was hoping
you could help me make them i will try
my best that's great so i did some
research great so the cookie you're
talking about it's pineapple jam like a
thick jam yeah yeah and cookie is very
delicate and soft i think i would
compare it to like when you take cookies
right out of the oven and they're still
hot and they're just like falling apart
i want to make
something that
very close to your memory yes so i think
to help us out today is our friend
nathan he's from you weren't born in
singapore i was born here and then
immediately shipped to singapore do you
have
a family recipe
yeah
so i think an auntie's recipe is
actually like the perfect place to start
it's a little vague but yes i really
love these drawings
can you draw the shape that you're
familiar with you have like the cookie
and it has like a cute little like
that's pretend that's round okay
and then there's just like the lump of
like the pineapple tart and then there's
like teeny tiny strings of dough that
just like
crisp
they look like a sunflower let's make it
and let's sell them
[Laughter]
oh this is a completely different
direction i love that our business plan
yeah
so let's make pineapple filling first
three cans yeah just go yeah four
just dump it all in yeah yeah
all right
[Music]
i'm pretty sure this is yes yes
how chunky
the filling it's very fine
it's like stringy stringy
pineapple has a lot of high bars yes and
sugar
yes
this looks
really i think so because the acidity i
don't
let's not talk about it
i don't know so pour everything into the
yum 250 sugar oh my god that's so much
sugar and cinnamon all right so this is
gonna just cook that's what the recipe
said cook until dry
while it's cooking let's make dough so
nathan's onto recipe says cream the
butter right but in order to achieve the
flaky texture
i want to try making like almost like
making pie using food processor using a
cold butter instead of creaming butter
and that will make it fluffier
it makes flakier because it's the air
pockets the butter it's cold butter
melts and kind of creates a layer ah
like croissants
after butter it's kind of like a sand we
can put wet ingredients yeah larp this
is going to come together
like a dough so when you start using
hand it has to be kind of quick right
because you have hot hands yeah so i'm
going to
chill in in a refrigerator
and i want to just like divide it in two
and also i'm gonna take
a small portion and just bake it
don't touch too much so i found two
cookie cutters it looked like a flower
shape yeah which looks right
uh if i'm thinking about picking one up
and putting it in my mouth
it's two bites and this is one light i
think this one okay let's try both
look
so cute
okay i'm gonna go over and bake it i
will try a 350 for 15 minutes bye bye
look at this
i think it's done i went ahead and put
it in a colander so that any other
liquid will just kind of dry out while
it
cools and dries cookie time cookies
let's eat it
[Music]
it's too dry
like it turns into sand in your mouth
this is a little flaky it is very pie
crusty
which i don't think is right okay right
[Music]
oh no not right it needs to be
softer so we are going to do creaming
method so instead of making the dough
like making a pie yeah we are going to
make the dough like making cookies so um
room temperature butter and instead of
using granulated sugar we are going to
use powdered sugar white it will make
the texture you like powdered sugar is a
little sweeter like reduced to 50 grams
oh okay yeah yep same amount
so we're doing wet instead of dry first
yes i already put baking powder oh okay
yeah yeah yeah
teamwork
sorry too enthusiastic yeah yes yes yes
yes yes incorporating it will create
gluten so we have to rest this dough
about 30 minutes because we do want
gluten or we don't want to gluten you
don't want to glue down because it's
going to be chewy and let's take a
portion and cook it like we did last
time yeah
you know what i feel good about this
okay
these look good i'm gonna go
in and over i'm going in you're going in
the oven great bye
bye so um i changed the temperature from
350 to 370 oops
is a little bit darker but it's okay
it's a test part
it smells so buttery
it like breaks cleanly
but it like
it's so soft in your mouth i feel like
it can be a little bit sweet i don't
know i think so right i reduced the
sugar to 50 but i think we can use 80
grams
yeah
wow
okay let's do it let's do it let's do it
final portion like how they say final
attempt attempt final answer answer okay
so difference is just the amount of
sugar but it was not sweet you know yeah
so let's cream it
making cookies cookie time
who am i okay
okay do you remember
do you remember next
step yeah we're gonna put in the fridge
yeah so it's this recipe it's going to
be carried over to your
my children yes
from one auntie to the next should we
test batches
no we know we know
dough's going in the fridge we'll be
back in 30 minutes
okay so our cookie dough is cold yeah
and we get to use this huh yeah big boy
big boy
wow why are you so much better at this
than i am i paid a lot of money going to
culinary school there okay so let's cut
it out so we tested both sizes and i
think we're gonna go with the smaller
one cookie cutting cookie cutting
so once you're done
make it fancy no
combine everything together and make
more
and then we're going to make a latkes
now for the pineapples let's see how
sticky they are
sticky
yeah
oh it's a bit big do you want to do a
tongue
oh
so cute
okay all right hands it is
they look like eggs
that's true eggs
that's cute
[Music]
last one do it okay
sticky high five no sticky high five
i hate on that field
my name is gladys and i love a lattice
all right so um i'm going to use ruler i
see that i'm just going to roll them in
my hands it's so cute
i have so much respect for these aunties
maybe i can become that neighborhood
auntie oh nikki oh that pineapple tartan
yeah do you want to try get in here yeah
i'm getting here maybe one day riya when
you and i are 80 years old we'll just
make cookies together yeah do you think
you can find me oh i will
i'll find do you think we are still
staying in touch of course i will make
sure of it
this is our old lady cookie plan
we're almost there yeah
[Music]
i'm going to brush with egg wash and we
are going to bake in 350 for 15 minutes
15 minutes great
show me the money
[Music]
well
is it going to remind you
the pineapple tart you ate when your
child is old i mean they look pretty
great yeah cheers cheers
[Music]
the taste the texture
this is it
that really like buttery flaky melt in
your mouth
[Music]
yes
it's good it's so good
i honestly
never thought i would eat these like
this again
i'm so happy to hear that
it's me too
thank you so much you're welcome
[Music]
yeah
yeah i did two
[Laughter]
[Music]